well the World Economic Forum in Davos
Switzerland is going on as we speak you
weren't invited
president Trump's Air Force one is one
of the biggest planes there but more
than a thousand private jets have also
showed up for the event spewing vast
amounts of carbon into the atmosphere
despite this global warming is of course
a big topic in Davos as it always is
when rich people gather many attendees
including Al Gore claiming we need
drastic worldwide action to save the
planet they want to ban cars commercial
air travel meat all to offset their
private jet use mark Stein has been
watching carefully he's an author and
columnist in front of the show he joins
us now to assess so I kind of like how
this works I fly in my private plane you
have to stop eating hamburgers and walk
and the kind of balance is out yes
that's that's right this is this is a
the way these guys plan that somehow
they will still get to jet around like
Al Gore in his private plane going to
world conferences Leonardo DiCaprio and
you will be beating your laundry down on
the rocks with the village women getting
your clothes dry because the washer and
the dryer are destroying the planet and
the fact that they all meet in a remote
luxury Swiss ski resort you said that
that your viewers weren't invited Tucker
and that's right most people aren't
invited because it's government leaders
and what they call so-called
stakeholders and apparently 90% of the
schlubs on this planet don't have a
stake in anything but cate blanchett
who's getting an award for raising
awareness of refugees she apparently
counts as a sacredly they should have
given the award for raising awareness of
refugees to the mayor of ash dish and in
Sweden who told the women of our session
that they now had so many refugees it
wasn't safe for the ladies to go out at
night that's who I de given me I don't
think we need Cate Blanchett to raise
awareness of another problem so you have
at Davos right now the leaders of the
world's largest democracies the economic
leaders the political leaders how many
of them do you think personally believe
in democracy for real I don't think they
and I think that's what's fascinating
about this they regard things like the
Trump election and brexit as and the
rise of say marine lepen in France and
the AFD in Germany they regard these
things as aberrations and as proof that
democracy has to be moderated by all the
sensible clever people getting together
in a Swiss ski resort kind of like the
Blofeld doing the spectre round table in
at the top of the magic now in the yeah
in the Bond film on Her Majesty's Secret
Service if you're keeping in touch with
your world conspiracies they all meet on
the top of a mountain like The Spectre
board meeting in James Bond films and
they decide the measures they can take
to ameliorate and moderate the voice of
the people because the voice of the
people is vulgar and keeps voting for
Trump and brexit and that kind of thing
but don't you think if you're gonna have
a global conspiracy of elites at least
the people involved should be impressive
and self-aware smart yes I think so and
I think it's become a rather sort of
third-rate pseudo-celebrity event as you
say the this idea that they're there all
the people with private jets it's a kind
of class thing so there's a lot of
layabout Saudi princes who fly in there
there's a lot of rather trashy
celebrities there's a lot of powerful
business leaders but at heart it is an
anti-democratic bias you mentioned that
hamburgers cause global warming that was
this story today I didn't actually
believe that but it turns out that if
you eat a breakfast sandwich from
McDonald's every time you eat a sausage
and egg McMuffin a polar bear loses its
ice floe apparently the sandwiches are
responsible for global warming
so as bad as it is Leonardo DiCaprio and
Al Gore flying around to these summits
on their private jets if they all flew
into Davos on a sausage and egg McMuffin
the entire planet would be kaput because
that's apparently what causes global
warming according to these guys ok next
January you and I are going let's do a
show from there that would be so yes and
we will go in on your personal terkelson
Tonight Show official sausage
egg mcmuffin magic flying plane as they
say next year in Davos mark thank you
that's right